[Music]
man i always love it i always love it
when people add
a new dimension
a new layer to something that's already
been established you know there's
already greatness there and they bring
something else
that you didn't think they'd have
especially later in a career who am i
talking about i'm talking about candace
parker
mike she's 34 years old
and today she was named defensive player
of the year in the wnba it's the first
defensive player of the year award she's
had in her career she's a two-time mvp
she's a finals mvp she's a champion
all-star has done so many things
in her decorated career and go back to
her career at tennessee she was great
there too yeah number one overall draft
pick i mean look at it
but now oh
something to be done she's done it if
there's something in basketball she's
done it yeah and and you know what i
like mike uh if you just look at the
award is appropriate because she had a
great season
but if you look at it
her numbers and this is not supposed to
happen
uh her numbers in a lot of areas are the
highest they've been in like seven or
eight years
you know her field goal percentage is
way up there her three-point percentage
is way up there
uh average almost 10 rebounds a game so
uh shout out to candace parker i wanted
to be sure
to talk about her in this show because
i'm a big fan
no i i like that we're talking about her
after you know leading off the show with
brianna taylor um
you know i want to celebrate this queen
you know i want to give her her flowers
you know
i i happen to
know candice pretty well i've gotten to
know her pretty well i want to overstate
it but i do consider her a friend
name driver no no it's just more i just
want to i just want to kind of it's
disclosure you know i i'm about to sing
a lot of praises uh about her personally
i mean you've laid out all her
professional accolades and she's one of
the best to ever play the game
um
and to i know it's important her to get
this award i think she posted on
instagram that this is going to go on
the top shelf because she thinks about
her late great coach pat's summit and
how pat summitt said offense wins
uh games
uh offense scores often sells tickets
defense wins games but rebounding wins
championships the rebounding part was
passed summons part so leading the
league at 9.7 rebounds a game was big
for for candice parker as it relates to
honoring her coach but no but candace
man i i i've only known him for a short
time it's one of those relationships you
feel like you've known him forever i
only really got to know her we had
crossed paths before i only really got
to know her
um
in february matter of fact i was at i
was at soho house in chicago
at all-star weekend and i'm having
dinner with mark spears
and candace parker walks in and she sits
down
uh because she knew spears better than
she knew me at that point
and again we knew each other but she
sits down and we have dinner and man i
mean
she's brilliant
she is every bit as brilliant off the
court as she is on it and you have one
conversation with her and listen the
country gets to know her
regardless how closely you follow the
wnba she's one of the best commentators
and analysts i love that in in
basketball
on tnt right now she's doing amazing
it's about time isn't it it's about time
it's about time but what yeah but but if
you but she's she's so
she has such broad interests such a
respect for history
such a knowledge and such a sensibility
i just want to give her props for how
she's used her voice and her platform in
this moment we focus a lot on the men
generally speaking most people focus on
the men that's in life but specific to
this athlete activists
you know
revolution we're in right now a lot of
times we focus on the men not enough on
the women in general but specifically
when you want to talk about the wnba
uh the wnba the the player who's
probably gotten the most love is the one
that's not playing that's maya moore and
rightfully so but candace parker man
never fails to use her voice never fails
to use her platform is a role model in
so many respects and an amazing mother
she will tell you her first job is as a
mother 11 year old layla she's an
amazing mother an amazing citizen just
an amazing person all around and i just
can't say enough about her i got some
other stories i'll let you get in on
this no say say one no
tell me one story because
uh we were talking about candace parker
uh a little earlier
and i was saying how impressed i am with
her and some of the some of the things
that you said as well
and you said there's a story with my son
and i said okay what's the story and of
course this is what michael smith
michael smith does this he says
i'll tell you on the air so so tell me
the story real quick man what's the
story yeah no so
you know again parenting is her biggest
passion she does an instagram live you
know show called uh parental
confidential that's her biggest passion
is parenting she's she's you know
layla's with her in the bubble right now
um
so we always talk about parents whenever
we talk on the phone and so my son was
struggling because you know
at the early in the pandemic he had made
the travel aau team
and he was so excited he was so excited
to have made that team he worked hard he
deserved it
but we weren't comfortable
once the team started back up we weren't
comfortable letting them go and travel
and be a part of it and he was obviously
upset he's like my friends are doing it
why can't i do it
so i told candace about it
and by the way back up ever since they
know that i've known candice parker they
try to eavesdrop on my conversations
with her she said hi to them before and
they just they're over the moment that
their dad knows candace parker right but
um
i i said hey will you talk to mason
will you explain to mason just kind of
like give him a little pep talk and she
was like
uh mason your parents are responsible
for you and not your friends and as you
know michael you say something and it
goes from one and out the other candice
parker says that my son's like that's
right okay whatever you say miss parker
whatever you say miss parker got it
you know
on nba 2k
he doesn't play with the lakers in
lebron my son plays with candace parker
and the sparks he played when he plays
2k that's who he plays with it candace
parker i think that's so cool to watch
my son
without me even having to push him
appreciate women's basketball and
professional female athletes the way
that he does but candace parker and i
don't ask athletes to talk to my kids
i'm not one of those hey can you say hi
to my son hey can you say hi to my
daughter if i get an autograph i've
never done that but i was comfortable
with candace talking to my kids because
of again the kind of person she is and
the kind of relationship that we have
you